so um I just want to ask you um how many
of you here consider her or herself like
an expert in cloud
computing called selection bias because
who which expert would come to Basics um
talk so let me introduce you to Emily um
Emily right here is a selft data
scientist as I think most of you are um
and this
just similar with most data tools um in
machine learning and science tack like
you know um I could learn make some tip
learning library and she's also
comfortable with creating web apps for
her models like she want to go and show
like her family oh I made this model to
detect this picture as of a cat or of a
dog um so at one point in time starts
working for awesome company um along
with Jacob is a learning engineer and
Noah who is a product mentor and yet one
day Noah comes and he tells them so
legal team wants a document
classification model um and at the
moment em starts thinking like oh cool I
can create a model and put it play in a
Dash app a stram app for the legal team
to outload your document and get it
classified and that's when Jacob goes
and says sure we can set up an's model
as a containerized lamb the function
triggered by S3 object uploads and
saving prediction to some Dy table
notifying legal scene whenever a record
for a document gets inserted using dyn D
streams and at that moment Emily look
like I have no idea no clue what this
guy just said so and given there um this
talk is very Lely for you um I want to
just list some points why I think cloud
computing knowledge is important for USD
scientist so the first one is going to
be you'll feel more confident when
designing Solutions so you'll understand
more the things that Jacob said um it
will help you bridge the gap between the
models development phase and it's the
deployment which is something I have
struggled a lot when working with data
scientists it would also give you
freedom to explore your personal
projects so once you have a project
running your local computer maybe you
know what tools to use to put it online
um this is a very important one it will
give your diving skills a 10x boost
which is crazy how much time you will
save in debugging and then understand
what is happening under the hood maybe
your company has a platform as a service
in which you go and click deploy and
send magic happens in Nat yes um so my
idea is that you understand what happens
there um this loock is going to have
three pillars the first one is going to
be compute as we need somewh to run our
models or data pipelines um the second
one is going to be storage as we need
somewh to save our data sets and
predictions and may our models to and
last one will be monitoring which is we
need to be able to identify when things
go wrong and why which is very important
sometimes we just put the model
projections just let everyone like go do
um the to is going to be around Amazon
web services is um kind of controversial
in Microsoft offices but anyways um
mainly because of market share and
secondly because of my personal
experience so I'm going to give you some
preliminary knowledge of AWS like some
general things um which are going to be
useful to you so the first one is AWS
infrastructure is composed of regions
and each region is composed of one to
many availability which I would call AC
because availability is a hard work um
this is a map of all the ads radiant
that currently exist
and as you can see in souo we have three
AC and you can think of every AC as a
data center so if one AC goes down and
you have your model running in three of
those ACS it's going to keep running
because um just one of them went down um
if you're wor with the console you very
likely have identified this bottom in
the top right corner in which you can
select your region and we can cause you
some headaches sometimes which you come
to the conso and you see you have any
instances running and it's because you
selected the wrong region just
that um then there's the concept of a
virtual private plow which is VPC which
is no more than a range of ips that is
assigned to um your account in one
specific region and then you have a Ned
which is a range of IP addresses inside
your VPC that can either be public um
these ones are accessible to the
internet or private which are not and
also you need to understand that some
resources um run inside VPC while other
is run in the AWS Network which which
means you would have to go through the
internet to access them there are some
exceptions and we which we can bypass
that one another and finally I handles
permissions via um identity and access
management I am um using polies which is
a Jon that looks like that like okay
allow this um um whatever I'm putting
this policy into to do this kind of
actions on this resource and think can
either be um attached to a resource or
an IM component like user groups and
roles
okay so compute um before I um start
this section I want to go over the
debate of full manage versus stes you
might have heard it so full manag means
you have to configure the scaling
provisioning networking of your servers
and virtual machines um you will get
Bill for the time that your virtual
machine is up which leads to some
unexpected costs I think everybody has
seen
those um and you're free to add any
dependencies and run most kind of
workloads um on this kind of machines
and then you have the server L which is
um you get automatic provisioning and
scaling of your resources you will get
built for execution time and not the
time that your machine is up um if it's
not doing anything for instance but you
will get a bit more restrictions laying
on the execution time pill size and the
code
size so um the main um service for
running full and managed uh virtual
machines on the cloud in AWS is last to
compute cloud is2 and for serverless um
it will very likely be Lambda um Lambda
is a function as a service service which
is serverless to and there are some
matter serverless um services like AWS
glue which I think most of you have used
and also AWS EMR has also released their
c verion um so what I was mentioning
about um the full managed card is if for
running an E2 instance which would be no
more than a computer running in the
cloud um you would need an AM which is
just our virtual machines OS so you got
a list uh to choose um like Linux macunu
and so much more they you need to choose
your instance type which would be
resources such as the amount of CPU and
Rand that your instance is going to have
then you'll need to um select the
settings for your networking um for
instance and which VTC you want to run
it and at which
subnet and finally the amount of storage
you want that instance to run so once
you've got all those four pillars you
can start running um your is to instance
and you can literally run most of the
things like you can host a web server
you can run high performance computer
workloads you can run a database if
you're brave enough um and you can run
analytical and machine learning tasks
and to infinity and beyond really
anything um that you can run on your
computer can be taken to the cloud using
um
ec2 and then we have lendo in which we
have two main requirements the one is
just code um you can just go to the
service complete the Lambda Handler and
that's how you get a function running
and then
memory and some of the main use cases
for LDA include event driven
applications um processing data streams
some small Shar running workloads and
micros services and if you're thinking
so can I run a model in a Lambda
function Yes actually one of the
companies we worked for we had all our
models running in a Lambda which made it
extremely cheap because we didn't have
to manage any servers um and we only got
built for the execution time of those
models and then containers come um so
how the containers work in
ATS luckily for you Londo comes already
with an integration with Docker so you
can run a Docker image um inside of
Lambda so that's quite cool you can get
running Docker inside of a E2 instance
which is basically what I mentioned if
you can as tall the docker end on in
your machine you can do it um in the ec2
instance and there's this this this
thing called elastic container registry
which would be um the equivalent to
dockerhub but in your AWS account so
that's where you would do like Docker
push um there and then Lambda would pull
Docker images from the
ECR and then another mention I want to
do is of container orchestration systems
so I think most of you might have heard
of this thing called kuber nettis which
kind of scares us a bit um but it's real
simple I mean it's it's just a bunch of
computers running which are called nodes
and we want to tell that container
registration system okay run so I want
you to run the stalker image which could
be the legal uh back end I don't want to
get two copies of this one running so it
just go like okay this one has available
resources I'm going to put it here and
then I'm going to put the second one
here and then it can go with my document
classification model service and tell it
the same but I want three of these
because I don't know I'm going to
receive more requests so I tell it get
through these running and goes okay put
it there there and there and that's the
basic of it that's all that kubernetes
as along some other things um what is
the cool thing about container
registration systems if a container
fails for whatever reason the system is
going to realize that and it's actually
going to create a new instance in
whichever available know it finds so
that's all you need to know um you very
likely don't want to create your own
container distribution system inside
your company just to run them model
because you will get a lot of cost upu
front but if you already have one um and
these are the two options that AWS gives
us um you can really talk to the like
the infrastructure team and put your
models right there so it gives us two
possibilities the one is elastic
container service and the other one is
elastic kubernetes service the main
difference is that the one on the left
is AWS proprietary meanwhile the one of
the right runs on runs kubernetes which
is an opp open source sofware
and then you have the serverless flavor
D which is um running on AWS tget which
is put in a container and a server to um
environment um if all this confused you
there's this awesome ads Compu Vision
tree credit suburan and which it not
only goes to services that I went over
but a lot more like machine learning
services and um analytical Services um
inside a AWS it's quite cool um and this
is the branch for um you know the
compete
Services moving on to storage um I want
to mention three storage flavors that
you can choose from the first one is
blob storage which is just putting files
in the cloud um the second one is like
traditional SQL um systems and the last
one would be a key Value Store um which
is a NQ one so for uploading files I
think most you have worked or at least
heard of simple storage service Amazon
S3 um for SQL I'm going to present to
you relation of database service and
lastly um for nosql you have different
services but I'm going to show you
Dynamo DB which is you know one of the
services that AWS T to people proud of
um just be in mind that you also have
different alternatives for um graph
databases like Neptune and time
databases like time
stream so simple Sur service um in
essence it cre uh allows you the
creation of buckets which are the core
component where your object will live
think of it like some kind of Drive hard
drive in the in the cloud and it each
object has its key um which is analogous
to a file's path so for example for a
full object um you would have it
identified as S3 which is a protocol
legal documents roow prod which would be
the bucket and finally the object P
which we can have I don't know Partition
by year month and day and then the file
in which would be some
D some interesting features include um
object triggers which means there are
many of these but I think the most
important one is when you get a new
object uploaded to S3 you can actually
trigger something else on another part
of
a then you have something called life
cycle policies which is you can Define
what um happens to the objects after
some time for instance after an object
is uploaded I want to delete it after 30
days because maybe it was something um
temporary then you have something called
stage
classes which Chang the availability of
your object um depending on how
frequently you want to access it so you
have like this standard class up to the
Glazer deep archive um and logically the
standard class tends to be more
expensive and the um glazure G archive
uh cheaper but also it takes more time
to retrieve an object from
archive then you have automatic
replication which means you can outload
an object to to an S3 bucket and
replicate it to another one
automatically versioning um
self-explanatory you can have an object
and just upload the same object and it's
going to stack layers of versions and
one cool thing is that if you excellent
delete an object which has happened to
me um you will just get a delete marker
and if you want to restore that object
just delete the delion marker and then
you have
it and so that's three is idea for
loading your data sets like tab images
audio and all kinds of um files that
come to your mind um it is cool for
creating data
legs and one other use case um it's cool
for hosting static websites so at this
company I work for we had a process that
uploaded an HTML um with a report to S3
and we actually um show that to
management in an easy way so we didn't
have to carry our notebooks or or
whatever they just went to that website
and they could see the report for the um
Matrix of the model and one important
thing is that um S3 runs on the AWS
Network so just burn that in mind um
then we have rdf relational database
Services uh service we have two
possibilities here the first one is that
we can run traditional SQL databases
like MySQL postgress and such which are
managed by a what do I mean with this
you just get an ec2 instance with the
database software for running and AD
will handle um software upd Secor
patches and such um and then you have
Aurora which is an ads proprietary
software but it is compatible with the
myql and postgress um drivers so if
you're using a post database in I don't
know Asher and you want to migrate to
Aurora um it's transparent to your
application um this database is run on
your VPC please don't put your database
on a public subnet unless you know what
you're doing um and then you have uh
here's a comparison of Aurora versus RDS
so in performance Aurora tends to be
better um they have storage scaling
Aurora both have automatic scaling but
Aurora has a bigger limit so if you
start getting your hard your discs full
it will actually expand
automatically um in Aurora you can have
up to 15 regr CEST so for those of you
that don't know most database clusters
tend to have one writer database in
which all rights go and then read
replicas which would um be used if you
want to corate a database but you don't
want to stress the writer database which
would be like the main one and in RDS
you can just get up to F replicas and
with no outo scaling you just have to do
it manually um failover is this thing in
which you have your writer database and
your reader replicas and if your writer
fails um you actually want to take one
of the re replicas and promote it to be
a new writer so you won't get any
downtime in your application in Aurora
it's automatic in RDS if you have mold
AC lots of stuff that's automatic a its
manual and pricing a tends to be more
expensive than RDS um but I think it's
worth it really unless uh you have good
reasons not to and finally we have dyam
which is a key Value Store very simple
you have a key um which matches to some
values so in Dynamo you have what are
called tables in this case we have the
people table
um and the keys would be the person ID
and the values would be any other field
that comes after so we would have the
last name the first name the phone the
address anybody who has worked with nol
databases know that this scheme are
flexible so if I want to add a new field
I don't need to run any migration or any
fun thing I just need to push a new
object there and I get a new
field it is AWS proprietary um I
recommend that you go and check the
history of dat it's quite cool it runs
in AWS networ and we wouldd have to go
through the internet to get there and
then some features include that you can
either use a partition key only or both
partition and short case very detailed
explation um then you can have Global
tables which means if you're running a
Dynamo DB database in the US and then
you want to deploy your application to
Australia then to reduce latencies you
can um replicate the data across the
world you have caching of re
um which is uh using G
um and then you have Dynamo EV streams
which be a change data capture feature
in which every time you put a record in
Dynam table it would send kind of a
notification uh which would which can
trigger different things in your
infrastructure um in the image we see
that every time um in your record gets
inserted it will trigger a lum the
function which can do some
other and then you have two flavors
which is either provision um which is
when you know what kind of workloads um
you're going to receive so your your
load is going to be predictable and then
you have on demand capacity which is
actually scale
automatic and finally monitoring um I'm
just going to go over the service
callede cloudwatch um because I think
most companies actually prefer using
some other um monitoring system like
kabana or you know spend all their bill
and data dog um
and cloud is quite simple uh service it
is the the facto service for monitoring
services in ads and it's used mainly for
handling logs metcs and
alarms and just some key line Concepts
you have what is called a log event
which would be a record of the Reser
application being monitored say when you
run logging theinfo one one of those
would be a log record you have a lock
Stream So if we go back to the um
container registration you can have two
of those running a lock stream would be
all the logs of one of those containers
and then your log grip would be all the
logs of absolutely all the
application um one cool thing is that
locks can be corded and filtered using
locks insights inside of a fly watch um
and then some Metric Concepts is that
you have many services that provide free
metric by default like for instance in
Lambda you get um the number of
implications and the number of Errors
you can also Define your custom metrics
for so for instance um I don't know I
want to send like the uh prediction a
model gave me and I send that metric to
cloudwatch and then you have alarms
which are defined based on value so um
if I go back I can just calculate the
ratio of Errors over um over
implications and trigger an alarm if
that goes over like I don't know
5% and as data scientist machine
learning engineers and such maybe you
have heard of s station maker um has
anybody heard a safe maker here and who
is using
it okay cool you're on the cool path um
why do I say this um so the first thing
is that I just want to transmute to you
that station maker tends to be just E2
instances running all the time um so in
station maker you have like station
maker pipelines which are no more than
machines spinning up all the time and
just running the code that you give them
um um we have all been there waiting
like a machine five minutes to start and
then failing which kind of sucks and
then you have the station sagemaker
endpoints um which are again no more
than ec2 instances Autos scaling groups
and stuff but all in all it's just easy
to
inst and last thing that I wanted to
mention here is and why do I go over
stage merer there's this thing called
the vendor lock in versus open source
tools which is is I think something you
need to have in mind all the time we're
working with Cloud providers so the
vendor lockin is when you um your
provider forces you to adjust your
projects to your vendor specifications
so for instance you have um your models
running locally and then when you want
to take them to Cloud um they give you
like okay but you need to implement all
this boiler plate just to get it running
in my
infrastructure and then you have open
source tools um which is not tied to any
specific vendor and they may be easier
to move um between them and it makes
really your your whole um development
phase more
flexible um as I mentioned running a
workflows on stage maker is tightly
coupled to using its a SDK and available
resources and as I said ERS tools are
not TI to any specific
vors so one of the Cool Tools that I've
found um line around is caml I really
recommend that you go check it out um
it's a tool in which you can declare
your pipelines and um inference
infrastructure in an abstract way and
then you can just run everything on the
different clouds like for instance and
the pipeline that we see below the
pre-processing um getting executed in
kuber is using spark um then the
training is getting executed in St Baker
and then we can finally deploy it to
aure so back to Emily based on what we
learned in this talk um and going over
Jacob
description all that he was mentioning
is having the LDA function which as he
said was containerized so we would have
a Docker image running in the ECR
service and the Lambda would pull the
image um and run the inference we can
also have an S3 bucket in which we will
put our models um our Ser models and we
can make um our function download those
models and run the the
inference and we can have another S3
bucket um for the legal steam to upload
the documents so automatically when they
upload a new document it would trigger
the execution of our LDA function we can
then sa the prediction for instance on a
Dynamo DV table and that would trigger
the execution of for instance a new uh
Lambda function created by the legal
steam which would be invoked via Dynamo
DV
streams